Good morning, everyone.
Good morning.
I want to say first off, thank you to PUBG for sponsoring this stream.
But yes, if you guys want to help out this stream, you can scan this QR code and do a survey.
Apparently, there's a lot of stuff.
It's about like what you guys feel about this game from watching the stream after the stream or even like during the stream.
If you guys can do the survey.
And if you do the survey, you have a chance to win a $50 Steam code.
Scan this code or
I'll show you guys the characters.
Like I said, there's like, there's, um, Apex, so, like, you can see.
Oh, my gosh, you can't see.
Oh, my God.
Explosive hammer.
Wait, I know what character to use.
Boom.
There you go.
I don't know.
We smashed.
This is the smash.
Okay, but I do have a shotgun.
See?
How bad is the flash?
Okay.
It's not, okay.
Yeah, I know.
It's pretty bad.
What's the drill?
Oh, I guess drill camera.
It's like, you start breaching.
Oh, wait, that's cool.
Oh, that's cool.
This is like Intel.
All right, here's the foam grenades.
I can build my own wall.
I can build one wall.
It's all right.
That one wall will clutch it.
This one, I was like, I'm going to heal myself.
And then like, it was just too much prep time.
Like, I know it was like two seconds, but like, I was getting chased at.
Like, there was no prep time for me.
All right, last girl.
Oh, this one.
This one was, she seems fun.
Only because like, the thing is, you can't really, you can do this.
and just like but also i messed up because i think it's also one bullet or two it depends on if you can grab ammo in time all right apparently i have to make the room i'll make the room right now hello hello hello hello i'm nervous i don't play a lot of tactical shooters so it's all on you moxie very nice did you try out all the characters i did i don't know who i'm gonna play to be wall that he holds out like a giant shield i'm gonna put that shield out yeah i'm gonna put that shield and you just shoot everyone okay okay i don't know they know you can shoot the toes yet so we'll see i oh yeah they probably didn't play the tutorial yeah that's true that's true they probably they probably don't know i don't know if you could change characters during that patch so we gotta commit to this yeah no this has got to be the strat this is we're committing because if we lose like We have no other strap behind.
Yeah, this is our only strap.
Collision.
Okay, don't shoot my head.
No, I said I don't see the mark.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, I got your friend.
To our right.
Oh, they're the same way.
They're the same way.
I think they're this way.
I don't know.
Do you think they're standing?
Oh, they're the same strategy.
Don't you.
Get away.
Oh, wait.
Hold it down.
Hold it.
I told you, Boxy, the mixture hits the grenade.
I don't have a grenade.
It's just a smoke.
Okay.
They did it himself again They did it himself.
We push up.
We push forward.
Nice.
We're broken up.
I can't like it.
Come on.
Here.
Oh, he's on.
I'm dead.
He's stuck behind.
What happened?
He's good.
Okay.
You guys are not bad.
He's good.
Press B and change your character right now.
Oh, you got him?
Yeah.
How do you heal?
I have grenades too.
Okay, I got...
I got...
I have it.
I could swap with the swap.
Okay.
Because...
Because they're using shields.
You're cheating.
I think our plan...
We should have kept with the shield plan.
I'm pretty sure.
Okay, I'm here.
I'm here with the shield.
All right.
We got this.
30 seconds.
Oh, my God.
Wait, we can catch up.
That's fine.
Let's do it again.
We were learning.
You know, we were figuring it out.
It took us a while to get the shield going.
The shield...
Okay.
She's right...
It's...
She's...
Flake him, flake him, flake him, yes!
Oh, behind me.
Oh, no, I'm so fucking.
Oh, my God.
They sandwiched.
We still won.
Look at that!
We should have done that.
No, no, no.
What?
We're winning.
This is so not what I...
I mean, I had a hundred percent play.
Thank goodness for...
What?
Honestly, I'm starting to think, like, maybe I'm not that good with a shotgun.
This is the only time I've gotten a kill.
With the guy who has a shield, I've only gotten kills with his gun.
I think they're going to go where we first met them.
You go in the courtyard.
Yep, yep, yep, you've seen them.
They're deep.
Oh, there's he- he's pulling out a gun.
The other guy has a gun.
Okay, I'm reloading.
I'm reloading.
You got this.
Nice, nice, nice.
He's one.
Oh, he's so close.
I'm here.
I'm here as well.
She's one.
Oh, he's speaking.
He's so low.
I'm here.
I'm here as well.
She's one.
Nice.
Oh, he's speaking.
He's so low.
I'm here.
I'm here as well.
She's one.
Nice.
Oh, he's speaking.
He's so low.
I'm pushing.
the reload after reload nice nice i see look at that we're figuring it out we figured it out we're low-key we got 15 seconds yeah just run like oh no no i'm stuck i'm stuck oh no it's a die is one dead no why okay now we've played events we win no we win no we win oh no it's a die oh no we gotta get killed we gotta kill him we gotta kill him we gotta kill him no we had it we had it we had it we why did we rush why did we no why do we do that No,
we're just, look, we're just bloodthirsty, okay?
We don't, we can't be patient.
We're just alpha.
Yeah, we're just, yeah, yeah, we're just alphaing it.
Okay, yeah, that's it.
Okay, this is search and destroy.
So, you know, like, how we have to plant or, like, breach walls.
So, we're attacking right now.
So, I don't know what to play.
Yeah, I'm not sure.
I'm not sure.
Maybe I should bring you a hammer guy out.
Because this is closed quarters, I feel like I should be playing shotgun.
You want to do a hammer guy or not?
If I can find him, no.
No!
Yeah, he goes next to me!
He goes next to me!
Oh, it's a motion.
Got motion detected.
They know!
I'm spotted.
They spotted you.
They're playing slow.
Oh, they're on that side.
They're over there.
One of my motion detectors went off, I think.
I'm going the other way.
I hear one on my left.
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Two of them.
Oh, wait, on the right over here?
I hear him.
Got him.
Okay, so they were actually...
Okay, so they actually...
They didn't go near us.
So, okay.
They actually didn't go to the side.
No, they baited me.
Yeah!
Let's go!
Oh my god.
Why did they push up their defense?
Yeah, they gotta hold the point.
Yeah, what?
Okay, so I have a hammer for defense.
I'm putting fences.
I'm gonna put fences on this wall.
Wait, I'm point A, you're point B?
Yeah.
I started at point B.
What do you mean?
I thought it was like a, I thought it was like a, like let him, you know, flip a...
Oh, that's true.
We could flip it.
That's true.
Should we do that?
Wait, wait.
I'll play out.
Oh, wait, I got a plan.
I'll play here.
If I die, I die.
Oh my god, wait.
I hear it.
Was that you?
Yeah, no, that was not me Yeah, they're over there They're on me He's one, he's one, he's one He's one, he's one, wait, he's not one Ah, shit She's at full No!
We got him!
Oh my god!
We did it!
We did see it!
We're gaming, we figured it out Their morale's demolished Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's so easy we won burst them tied you have foam walls oh i feel like this is a free breach yeah yeah i feel like they foam themselves off by the way cover me cover me yep yep yep yep yep yep yep oh we're in there i'm going to oh my god oh my god oh my god i got one i got one i'm so i think the other guy's in the hole yeah the other guy's in the hole oh my god bro he's just using the wall she can't do anything oh she's trying nice she can't i can breach that wall you think we're doing this i think they don't can't hear the crouch are you ready i'm gonna breach it three ready to breach the wall i don't see them okay i'm actually loki really scared i mean i'm so paranoid right now i'm putting sticky bombs literally everywhere i think i won't hit those i promise i won't actually walk out yeah stay away from those because i'm gonna blow them all up at once i'm so paranoid maxi where are they why are they dying i
don't know do i shoot this barbed wire oh you can't shoot it no oh my god they're right here they're right here try to back up and give them that where the sticky bombs are and i'll blow them up oh that's right right you know when you you like oh that guy's one right oh should i let him go on the side oh no i'm not okay i'll come over from the other side i went in the world i got it i got it no i'm so bad about that no no it's he threw a grenade after he hit me like 80 it's over oh he knows how to throw grenades i i don't i don't know how to throw grenades how do you do that i am one hp moxie i've looked at my health fire i should not be alive you're trying to make no hp i'm not trying to make me be oh my god oh my god she's over there okay he's do it he's behind there okay i'm just gonna be i'm just gonna be i gotta go be okay okay oh i'm down i'm down he's on she's on the other side you can plant you can plant you can't plant you can't oh my gosh i hear him wait he's planting on b he
is he is he is he is he's got to go through the door he's all the way right i think peekaboo no no no yeah you like that you like that yeah let's go a fish okay so apparently they're gonna be uh sending two people to each of our team number one the game producer yeah he's got a number one to the game producer he got the game producer all right i believe in us we have my fans i believe in them go go in guys go get going guys you got it oh my god i'm still still because i wasn't expecting myself to shot it wait i can preach this are you ready okay i guess you'll just shoot We're already ready.
I'm going to breach.
I'm going to sacrifice my life, right?
Three, two, one.
Breach!
Go in!
Get the producer!
Okay, you... Producer down.
Producer down!
I have med kits next to me, but only next to me.
Wait, I see a guy.
I have an angle on a kit that's so far away.
They're on me.
They're on me!
I got one!
Oh my god, he's low.
Nice.
Where's the last guy?
it's just you we we fumbled wow we actually fumbled the bag he's on here we got a cover we got we just wait we just make him wait crossfire crossfire oh yo oh my god he's on he's on the oh you're so clutch it's up to you moxie you still have a minute is he on the right i don't know i can't see he's right behind you he's finding you in that wall he's finding you in that wall might breach my thing.
I'm actually so scared.
He's right there.
Oh, he's right there!
So close!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
He was alive?
Did you just kill him?
How did I not hit him once?
Wait, I swear I should have hit him there.
Oh, you hit him.
Come on!
Oh, come on.
He thought he was sly.
Oh, you tried a corner peek that.
Let's go!
Yeah, no, he's pissed.
He's pissed.
Oh, my God.
Let's go.
We don't need the producer.
No, we don't need the producer.
We don't need it.
I'm baiting this other game.
There's this other guy on my I'm on my ass right now Oh my god he's one he's one Oh my god he's actually one He's flanking yeah he's flanking Oh no he's coming back he's walking back he's walking back But he was one HP That's TwitchCon number one he's one HP Oh my god you're both one Oh my god oh my god I had him I don't think it's 10 seconds We aren't breaching anything Oh they were all over there They asked.
Wait, they sent the TwitchCon people as meat shields.
That messed up.
They're sending them as intel.
They sent them as intel while they camped.
Oh my god, they're both low.
Oh my god, I'm an idiot.
That's what happened.
Oh, they're both low.
They're both very low.
Oh my god.
We can't get out of here.
Oh my god, we barricaded ourselves so we can't get out.
We gotta get out.
How do we get out?
We lock this.
That's how we did it.
Oh my god.
There's nothing I can do.
I have a shotgun Oh my god.
Okay, this is bad.
This is bad.
Oh my god.
They threw so many dates Both myself and the dev are going.
Oh Two staff members are coming in now.
Oh, I guess they swap.
They want the smoke instead.
Yeah, yeah, yeah Oh my god.
I'm so paranoid right now know it oh my god oh my god i was not expecting that nate going crazy well one of them shot me through the wall yeah that's what i'm saying you can wall bang it oh my god they got cross on me oh it doesn't matter i'm just gaming wait what wait oh wait they finally fired me he just killed you he killed me i was like what i got friendly fire this is a close game oh my god What is he doing there?
He was trying to hammer you!
He really said hammer down.
They tried her both trying to...
It's even game.
It's no longer even.
Oh, he's even again.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, I just got hammered.
I just got hammered bad.
They got the win off that?
No!
Moxie!
You gave them the win off that.
ggs everyone thank you again to pubg for the sponsor you guys see if you guys can check out the survey that's pinned in both our chats and also the qr code fill that out because it does help out the stream a lot wishlist that game right now hey guys i'll see you guys later everyone bye everybody bye